[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK,
we'll get started on time.
If you look at the
reading list and scroll
down to where we are, which
is Dynamics and Programming,
you'll see Lecture 6 there.
There's a chapter on Varians,
which is starred, called Time.
That's because the
application today
will be featuring
dynamics and what
happens over various dates.
And we're going to do it
in the context of a storage
problem, where people were
close to starving to death, as
in the medieval villages.
And that is Chapter
3 of "Medville."
It's also starred, which
fills out even more
than I'm able to in one CLASS
the material for the lecture
today.
So that's the reading list.
Then there's study guide.
So I went back
and earmarked what
we did last time,
which was Decision
Making under Uncertainty,
Linear Programming.
Some of these
questions are worded
as if you were doing it at home.
But nevertheless, the question
asks about important concepts.
So let me read the first one.
Draw a consumption
set which consists
of discrete number of points
argue that th set is not convex
and then show how
lotteries which put mass
on these discrete points,
transforms the consumption set
into something convex.
So there's two sentences there,
effectively two questions.
Could I get a volunteer, please?
So you can't actually draw it.
Can you describe
a consumption set?
Maybe these words suffice.
Try to describe, in words,
a consumption set which
contains a discrete
number of points
and tell me why it's not convex.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I think we
discussed this earlier.
But one consumption
set was consuming lunch
in New York at noon
versus consuming lunch
in Washington, DC at noon.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's true.
AUDIENCE: So that would be
a discrete consumption set.
And since you
can't consume lunch
in a mixture of
those two cities,
then the consumption
is not convex.
But if you had a sum
probability of eating lunch
in either location, then
you could have a probability
between zero and one.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: And
how would you draw it?
AUDIENCE: So for the original
discrete consumption set,
you'd just be two points.
I think one of those
points would be one,
zero and one of those
points will be zero, one.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Good.
And can you imagine how--
I'll help in a second
if it's not clear--
can you imagine how you
would be able to convert
that set into something that
is convex, using the lottery?
Is there something you
could draw to depict it?
AUDIENCE: If you just sort of
drew a line between those two
points, like your
location, instead
of doing how many lunches
you eat at DC and New York,
you could do the probability
that you eat at DC or New York.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Exactly.
So now we have a line
running on the diagonal
from one, zero to zero one.
The end points are still there.
Those are lotteries
that are degenerate.
They're putting probability
one on each of the endpoints.
An intermediate lottery, a
non-trivial lottery, say,
halfway between, would
put probability 1/2 on--
would be distance 1/2 to
one, zero and distance 1/4
to zero, one.
And that represents an
equal weighted probability.
And you can inch closer to
one endpoint or the other.
Those are still
non-degenerate lotteries.
So a lottery, when you
put a point in there,
represents the weights.
But yes, your
answer was perfect.
Thank you.
Questions about that?
OK.
What does risk aversion imply
about the consumer's utility
function?
Again, I'll take volunteers.
AUDIENCE: If you're
risk averse, then you
have diminishing marginal
utility of income.
So the utility function
should be concave.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Good.
Strictly or weakly?
AUDIENCE: Convex?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Let me repeat.
The question says what
does risk aversion imply
about the consumer's
utility function.
So your answer, concave, yes.
And I'm asking back, you
mean strictly concave,
weakly concave.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I think it
would be weakly concave, right?
Because if you have
a straight line--
or actually would that still
be considered risk averse,
if your utility from
getting a certain value
is like completely equal
to the utility of having
that as your expected value?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: All right.
That's perfect.
You figured it out.
So the answer is we typically
think of risk aversion
to mean strictly
averse to the lottery.
And hence, the linear case of
the linear utility function,
or weekly concave
function, but not
strictly concave, we
call them risk neutral
and not risk averse.
But I never said that in class.
So I'm amplifying.
But yes, risk aversion
is being risk averse.
Strictly speaking implies
strictly concave utility.
So perfect, thank you.
So one more here.
This, again, is going to require
you to describe something.
Combining states and time of
the world, time and states
of the world, what is the
complete commodity space
for a consumer?
And what I'm really
looking for is
for you to describe to me the
tree of possibilities that we
had on the slide last time.
And, again, I'll
take volunteers.
AUDIENCE: So this is a tree
that's oriented upwards.
And so at where time increases
as you go up in this tree.
As you make a specific
choice at any given time,
you limit your future
options to some specific set,
and you exclude some others that
are no longer possible for you
to consume.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
So the tricky part
of it is to remember
that the state of
the world at any date
is not just a set of
possible realizations
of the contemporary shock.
It also includes the history
of shocks, up to and including
the contemporary date.
So that's what's going
on with that tree.
You pick a node in the tree.
It's described not just by
the set of all things that
could have happened
on the current branch,
but the set of all things that
could possibly have happened up
to and including that point.
And actually, I made
the comment in class
that one has to consider
whether you're already
at the current date, or
whether you're at date zero,
imagining what could
happen in the future.
Because if you're at
zero and imagining
what could happen in
the future, then you
have to delineate all
possible histories
and all possible states that
can happen in any given date,
including up through and
including the date in question.
Great.
OK.
So, again, I earmarked
some of these.
I only went through
three of the four.
That was very helpful.
Thank you.
OK, so the lecture today is--
so this is on dynamics
and dynamic programming.
It's going to focus
on this application
for medieval
villages on storage,
or call it inventory, or
carryover, as well as the seed
that they put in the ground.
And I'll come back
to that momentarily.
And if you go back to the
economic science lecture,
this lecture is illustrative of
something we call calibration.
So you have a model of the
way the world works and you
find, somehow,
parameter values that
are appropriate for the model.
And then you simulate
the model and figure out
how well it fits the data.
And if it fits reasonably
well, then it's
a success, that you have
a logical explanation
of in an artificial economy
of how the world actually
works, or in this case,
past tense, was working.
There should be another
bullet point here.
Because I like to feature and
earmark that when it comes up,
we go through
various techniques.
And the technique that's
going to become apparent
is dynamic programming.
So most of the lectures up to
this point, not all of them
were static.
We made an exception with
that interest rate and income
and substitution effects and
a couple of the consumption
set diagrams.
So time is playing
a big role here.
And so if we're going to
solve a problem or program,
it's going to be
a dynamic program.
And there's some
useful techniques
that fall right out of
the end of this lecture.
So we're going to talk about
actual and potential use
of risk reduction arrangements,
namely carrying over grain
from one year to the next.
This first line
says alternative,
begging the issue of what
else have we looked at.
Well, we looked at an individual
putting his strips of land
all over the village.
And I referred to that as
portfolio diversification
at one point.
We looked at, and we
are about to see, again,
the picture of the estates
of the Bishop of Winchester,
which were spread
out over space,
arguably, again, to diversify.
And now we're going to
be stuck in one village,
and effectively, with one
person in one village,
on his or her own, looking for
alternative ways of reducing
exposure to risk.
Now the stylized
facts, if we go back
to the same Bishop of
Winchester accounts,
we don't see a whole
lot of carryover.
There are one estate at
the time, rare spikes where
a carryover jumps up.
And then the next
year, it's down.
I should say, or
this comes up later,
"carry over" means carried over
from one harvest to the next.
Obviously, time passes by
the day and by the month.
They only produce
one crop a year.
They have to have something
to eat during the interim.
So there is some
storage going on.
The issue is
whether, by the time
they get to the next
harvest, there's
any storage left at all.
And if there is, we
call it carryover.
Well, likewise, if you look
at the same estate accounts,
at a point in time, you
can see that some of them
have carryover.
But most of them don't.
So this model is going to
be similar to a macro model.
That probably doesn't
mean much to you
right now, a neoclassical
growth stabilization model.
We're going to put in two
kinds of storage technologies,
grain in the bin for storage,
but also seed in the ground,
because that's another way
to carry over the crop,
by planting it.
And we're going to
choose the parameters
to be consistent with
the available data.
And we're going to, again, look
at the numerical predictions
of the model and see if we can
match the fact that carryover
was not common.
This goes more into
how uncommon it
was where, if they're not
carrying anything over,
and there's only one
person in a village,
like Robinson Crusoe
as an abstraction,
then they're eating
all their output--
well, maybe-- over a
12-month time period.
So variability in
consumption is one to one
with variability in output.
And if output varies a lot,
that's a lot of risk to bear.
We have data from
that same lord.
Treating him as the
single villager,
we can look at output
as representative output
in the population and see,
in the cross section in 1236,
only three of the 18
states had carryover.
In a good year,
there was carryover.
1223 was good, for
example, for one
of those estates with
57% of the crop being
stored till next year.
And the following year for
that same estate, 1224,
zero carryover.
This is a review picture.
These are the estates of
the Bishop of Winchester.
And as I said last time,
it's hard to figure out
what country you're in, let
alone where you are in it.
But this is the English
Channel down here.
So all these dots are the
Bishop's of Winchester estates.
So that's the context
that's generating the data.
OK, two ways to store,
well, actually, four.
We're going to adopt two of them
and rule out the two others.
Not model the two
others, I should say.
In the artificial
economy, first, grain
can be stored after harvest,
as I've been saying.
Second, they could take
some of that harvest
and put the grain in
the ground as seed
planted for next year's crop.
The other things we're not going
to consider is taking the grain
and feeding it to the animals.
And eventually, you
might kill the animal.
So in some respects, you're
carrying over the calories
from the grain.
But it's not very efficient,
since the animals are also
surviving on the grain.
So we don't have
animals in the model.
Another more humorous
possibility is beer.
So they would take the grain
and ferment it and make
barley malt, for example,
which English people still
like to drink quite a bit,
no doubt due to this history.
But we're not going
to do that either,
no drinking in the model.
So let's take this
storage possibility.
The most obvious one
is you take the grain
and put it in the bin,
and potentially have some
left or not by next harvest.
How the depreciation rate being
delta, why does grain go bad?
Well, in England, it's
a very wet climate.
If it gets wet, and the grain
gets wet if it's not secured,
it spoils.
Mildew, even if it doesn't
directly rain on the grain,
is not good for the grain.
And grain gets eaten by
rats and other rodents.
And you may think
that's humorous.
But it is real.
I know in Thailand,
we would go and look
at what they call the rice
bank, which was a shed where
they had stored the rice.
And they were
showing us the shed.
And as they opened the door,
all these mice ran out.
So we're eating the grain.
How big is delta?
We have to calibrate this model.
So drawing from McCloskey, you
can see prices increasing month
after month after
month, from harvest
up through the next month.
And from this fact, McCloskey
gets a depreciation rate of 30%
So here's that table
that he's using.
Between September and
October, grain prices
inflated by 3 and 1/2%, between
October and November, 2 and.
1/4%.
So these are kind of grain
price inflation rates
through the year.
And roughly, if you add them
up and do a little compounding,
you'll get 30%.
Now who cares?
Well, let's imagine that
whatever you store at one date,
you get back 1 minus
delta that number,
say, the following month.
It's linear.
You don't get out what
you put in 1 to 1.
If the depreciation were 30%,
you put in 1, you get back 0.7.
You put in 10, you get back 7.
It's linear.
The storage technology displays
constant returns to scale.
If you were a firm
maximizing profits
by the choice of how
much to store over time,
you would be thinking
about this constant returns
to scale technology and asking,
how much would they be storing,
depending on how much
the price next month is
relative to the price today.
So it says exercise.
So I urge you to
write that down.
I did it just to make
sure this morning.
It's, like, maximize
P1 times y minus i,
where i is investment, plus
P2 times Y2 plus i multiplied
by 1 minus delta.
It's kind of silly to be
describing this in words.
Now what do you know about
constant returns to scale?
You already know,
with constant returns
to scale when we did the
Production Lecture 4,
that the solution is either
infinite or indeterminate
or zero.
Well, it's not indeterminate.
And it's not zero, either,
because they were storing
from month to month, at least.
So the premise is that, in order
to compensate the economics is,
in order to compensate
for the loss of the crop,
rather than selling it
today at a certain price,
they can sell it
tomorrow they're going
to have 70% left, a 30% loss.
So the price has to accumulate
at 30% over the year.
I'm going back and forth
between month and years.
Sorry.
So that's the
economic intuition.
And you already know the math.
So that's one
advantage for us having
spent some time on production
and, in particular,
on profit maximization.
So you know how McCloskey is
calibrating parameter delta.
Second possibility is
putting seed in the ground.
Now it turns out that's
a pretty healthy return.
We have some data on that.
And the yield to seed
ratio is about 2.6
for one of these manners
and 1.67 for the other one.
So that's a yield-to-seed
ratio, meaning you get roughly,
taking the average,
two units of output
for every units of input.
So that's pretty productive.
So if we stopped
right there, you'd
say, well, putting
seed in the ground
is a lot more productive
than depreciation,
even setting aside the risk.
Well, so there's a
couple of things.
One, there's a limit to how much
seed you can put in the ground.
And two, we're going to
be considering the risk.
So here's the technology.
If you planted Kt units--
put Kt seeds in the
ground, at t minus 1,
the output would be a
function f of that amount
of seed, the harvest.
And there's some shock epsilon.
In fact, let's assume this
is a linear technology.
So whatever seed got
put in the ground,
alpha times it is the output.
Alpha could be 2.
And epsilon is a shock that's
going to make it random
and make it move around.
OK, first thing, you can't plant
an unbounded amount of seed.
In fact, the best way to think
about this is the seed per unit
land is constant.
You have so much
land, there's no point
in putting down more seed.
So it's really a decision
about how much land to plant.
And we'll put an
upper bound on that
because there are
finite land holdings.
So K bar is going to be the
most land that you can plant.
You plant all of your land.
And if you were to try
to put down more seed,
it's like throwing it away.
You're still going to only
have the maximum amount,
K bar in this case
times epsilon alpha.
So we're about ready to
get to a key equation here.
Let's do it this way.
If you focus on
equation 1, you've
got output f, harvest, which is
a function of the seed planted
last year plus an
influence of epsilon.
Now you could have had
something in storage as well.
Imagine they had
done both things.
So they put some
seed in the ground.
And they had some storage.
You're going to get
1 minus delta times
that amount of storage back.
And that would be the end of
the story for consumption,
except they have to
plan for next year.
So they still have these two
options, storage planted now
at t that will be
available at t plus 1,
and seed, which they
can squirrel away now,
which will be
planted and influence
the harvest at Kt plus 1.
It's kind of weird dating.
Please be alert to that.
In fact, the last slide for
today will change the dating.
Different people use
different conventions.
What I'm complaining
about, or alerting you,
is this is
consumption at date t.
And these things, seed in
the ground and inventory,
have a date t on them.
But they are predetermined
from t minus 1.
They are not decision
variables at t.
The decision variables at
t are labeled t plus 1.
The pro case for
doing it this way
is that we care about the state
variable at a given day t,
and that's determined by the
seed that they planted before
and the inventory that
they have from before.
Anyway, just to alert you.
I trust you will interrupt
me when you have questions.
So this is the amount
that's available.
This is the amount that you
squirrel away for next year.
And the difference
between what's available
and what you store in one way
or another is consumption.
Now the risk averse, we
discussed that a minute
ago, so this is a
strictly concave utility
function over consumption over
a finite number of dates t.
So this runs from 1 to
capital T. Hopefully,
capital T is really
a long time away.
And I'll come back to that.
Alternatively, I
could have written
cap T equal to infinity.
They live forever.
But we're not quite
ready to do that.
So I'm just going to show
you finite time horizon first
and then argue how to extend
it at the end of the class
when we get to
dynamic programming.
There's a discounted utility.
Beta is a discount rate,
beta some number less than 1.
So you care about
the present more
than you care about the
future, present utility
more than future utility.
This is, with beta
less than 1, geometric.
You can see, as the horizon
gets further and further away,
you care less and less relative
to today's consumption.
But these are strictly concave,
so you don't like variability.
We talked about
concave utility when we
introduced the concept of risk.
Here, even if there
were no risks,
they would try to avoid
variability in consumption.
They'd rather have the
same consumption every day,
rather than having it low
one date and high another.
Because the utility
consequence of that
would be less than
having the same amount.
So that's where the context
drift concavity is coming in.
So we already calibrated the
depreciation rate at 30%.
The discount rate we're
going to put at 0.95.
Which is kind of standard,
although we could vary it,
we could make it lower.
Once we have the
program written,
we can plug in whatever we want.
Ideally, though,
the spirit of this
should be that we're somewhat
confident about these numbers
we're about to choose.
Constant relative risk aversion,
I defined that utility function
last time.
That's seed to the gamma
divided by sometimes normalized.
And we're going to
set that at 0.5.
This is kind of a low number.
It's definitely a
strictly concave utility,
but they may have been even
more risk averse than that.
However, you'll see this ex post
justification that all three
of these numbers
kind of work in terms
of explaining the paradox.
Namely, they're about to
starve to death every 12 years.
And they weren't
storing anything.
That's the paradox.
Back to that epsilon,
this is the way
you put the uncertainty in.
One unit of land planted
today yields two tomorrow.
So that's the
yield-to-seed ratio.
But there is a
little uncertainty.
10 out of 12 times,
you get 2 tomorrow.
But 1/12 of the time,
you get 1/2 of it.
And 1/12 of the time,
you get 4, double it.
So the expected yield
is a little bit above 2,
since the weights, 1/12 are same
on the low and the high end.
But 4 is 2 times greater than 2.
And the difference
between 2 and 1 is just 1.
So it's just the expected value
is slightly higher than 2.
We're going to set the
upper bound on storage at 1.
And this number, 1/12,
I actually just set y.
And you may be reminded
of that when you go back
and look at, in the data,
the coefficient of variation
that we introduced
last time of yields.
It was 0.35, which meant
roughly every 12 years,
output fell below less than
half of the mean value.
So we called that disaster last
time for these scattered plots.
So this mass over here under
the solid density is 1/12.
[INAUDIBLE] it's also
true they could get lucky
and have a high yield.
So you saw this
picture last time.
I'm really just using
it to remind you
of the context of where
the risk is coming from.
We wanted-- we
just did calibrate
the yield-to-seed
ratio in such a way
as to deliver disaster
every 12 years, on average.
OK, so let's look at the
dynamic decision problem.
Let's call this the
total available this year
and denote, on the
y-axis so to speak,
the amount of each of the
possible savings decisions,
either of storage or planting,
back to the key equation.
The amount available is
this, output plus storage.
And the savings decisions
are inventory or seed.
So that's what's being plotted.
But we are varying the
total amount available
going from 0 to 6.
And let's look at--
oh, where is this coming from?
So we actually
solved this problem.
We maximize 2
subject to 1, putting
in all these parameters.
And I didn't show you the code.
You can solve it on
Matlab or something.
I'm not asking you to do that.
But anyway, it's, like, this
picture could be anything.
It's pinned down, because it's
the solution to a max problem
at the calibrated parameters.
So this is our model version of
what they were doing, in fact.
So if the total amount available
was a little less than 1,
then they were not
planting all the land,
despite that high yield.
However, for anything else,
they hit the upper bound,
and they plant
everything they can
at the upper bound, which was 1.
Let's look at the
storage decision.
As a function of
the total available,
it's only when the total
available is 3 or higher
that positive storage kicks in.
And when it does,
it's moving linearly
with the amount
available this year.
It's actually not moving 1 to 1.
If it were 1 to 1, higher
available means higher storage,
it would be parallel
with this 45 degree line.
But it's not.
So they never store 1 to 1.
They may store less
than the harvest.
But they are storing
some, something here.
All right.
So those are the savings plans.
Things to keep in
the back of your mind
when we go through some
of the other slides
is the fact that mostly they
put all the seed in the ground,
but not when the amount
available is less
and the amount of
storage is zero,
unless the amount
available is above 3.
Now how much is consumption?
Well, back to this
thing, so consumption
is the difference between the
amount available and those two
savings decisions.
So if you look at this
diagram, consumption
is the difference between
the amount available
and the sum of these decisions.
This 45-degree line
is now playing a role.
Because the amount
available, say, 2,
go up to the 45-degree line.
Then this amount is 2.
That's the definition
of the 45-degree line.
Right?
It's a way to convert
the units on the x-axis
to the same amount
on the y-axis.
That's convenient here.
Because we can
look at, OK, here's
the amount that would
be available next year
if they didn't save anything.
But they are storing
in this case.
So consumption is the difference
between this 45-degree line
and the sum of these
two other lines.
That means that as
we get over here,
the 45-degree line is really
close to the only thing they're
doing, which is planting
seed, and very close.
So when you have less than
1.1 available this year,
they're still eating.
And they're not
planting all the land,
but they're not eating much.
It's a really hard problem.
Do we starve now
or starve later?
I mean, they kind of gamble on
getting a reasonable return.
If they ate the seed, they
have nothing tomorrow.
They're starving
to death for sure.
In fact, I don't if you've
heard this expression,
don't eat the seed corn.
Yeah, that came right
out of this episode.
Eating the seed corn is the
worst thing you could do.
Because you're kind of
guaranteeing zero for tomorrow.
But they actually do cut back.
They eat some of it.
OK, so this is a related way
to think about the dynamics.
Let's take total
available this year,
implement those two
savings decisions
on the previous
diagram, and then ask
how much are you going
to have next year.
Sorry if I'm belaboring this.
This is the amount
available this year.
You can save it or eat it.
If you save it in one or the
other of these two devices,
we're now talking about the
first part of this equation
with the two terms.
But the date would be t plus 1.
So this would be the
amount available next year,
given the amount available
this year and the endogenously
determined-- oh, I used that
word for the first time--
endogenously determined
savings decisions.
So here, we can't plot
savings and the total amount
available unless we're in
some 3-dimensional space.
So the savings decisions
are suppressed,
though they're still active.
Well, first of all,
output is stochastic.
Epsilon could be and likely to
be medium, but it could be high
or it could be low.
So the amount that's available
next year, even given
the savings decisions,
will vary with the epsilon.
So if you had three units
available this year, which
is right on the
margin of storing,
say zero, the most likely
outcome next year is medium.
And hence, there would be two
units available next year.
And so there would be no
storage next year, either.
So what do those
words correspond to?
You're at three
units available now.
The most likely outcome
next year is medium.
The amount available
next year is two.
And, again, from the
savings decisions,
storage at three and at
two is zero, so no storage.
So this is like what
would happen over time.
But let's just come back.
Suppose we redid
this experiment,
and you had two units
available this year,
and then you got
the medium output.
You would have two units.
So what does that referring to?
If we have two units
available this year,
and you had the medium output,
which is the most likely thing,
you get 2 units available
for the following year.
So two in and two out is
the most likely outcome
if you start with two.
So you could refer to that
as a kind of steady state,
meaning things aren't moving.
Actually, they are moving.
So technically, it's
not a steady state,
because we picked
a particular shock.
But it is the most likely shock.
So it's approximately true
that if you have two today,
you're going to
have two tomorrow.
But if you had two units
available this year,
and you got the low output,
epsilon 1/12 being probability,
the output available
next year is about one.
And at that point, you're
not planting all the land.
So that's over here.
You could have two today
and get really unlucky
and have less than two
available, about one available
next year.
And, again, if you memorized
a bit, those savings diagrams,
with one available,
you're not storing.
And you're eating
some of the seed.
So let's go the other way.
Suppose you had two units
available, which is, roughly
speaking, a reasonable starting
point, and you got lucky
and got the high output.
Then you would
finally be storing.
Suppose you had two, and instead
of getting the medium yield,
you got the high yield.
Then you'd have four
units available next year.
And at four units
available, there's
definitely storage going on.
So that's carryover.
Rare, but it can happen.
Does it persist?
Well, suppose, just to
run this experiment,
that you get lucky
and lucky and lucky.
So where would you end up?
You'd end up at roughly
a little above four.
Four replicates itself,
four in, four out.
It's on the 45-degree line.
So that's the best
case scenario,
that you would converge to that.
And you would be storing.
But I'm sure you
can see this coming.
If you were at that fortunate
situation with storage,
you got a medium or low output.
Then you would climb
back below three.
And you wouldn't
be storing at all.
So they had carryover once
in a while, but not often.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes?
AUDIENCE: If the
depreciation rate goes down,
then the inventory
line will move, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It
will move up, yeah.
It would shift up.
Well, it would not only
have a higher slope,
but it would kick in earlier.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So it is also implied that
in the medieval England maybe
the depreciation
rate was so high,
so the carryover was so
low, or we cannot observe
the carryover.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Say that again?
AUDIENCE: I mean, maybe it
implies that in the medieval
England, the depreciation
rate is so high,
that is why we cannot
observe the carryover.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
Well, if--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
I mean, we picked
it to try to match the data.
You could run the model with
a higher or lower number.
If we make the depreciation
rate less severe,
so it's like 20% or 30%,
they would store more often.
And then we would have
to look at that diagram
and see whether
carryover is still rare.
I mean, I imagine if
you go from 30% to 28%
or even 25%, not too
much might change.
But it's clear if you ran
the depreciation to zero,
then they're going to
be storing quite a lot.
They would have
a way of carrying
the crop over one to one.
It would still be
uncertain, but that
would be a big
step toward keeping
their consumption steady.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So no, it's a great question.
Because that parameter and
all the other ones are key.
We could vary each,
one at a time.
We could make them more
risk averse, for example.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That would
be an interesting experiment.
Then they're going to be more
worried about that low output.
And that probably
means they're going
to be trying to maintain
more seed and more inventory,
which one I'm not quite sure.
Well, there's an upper
bound on the amount
of seed, the amount of
land they can plant.
So that's probably going
to push inventory up.
That's a version of what we saw
last time in a static context.
Namely, that you're
willing to accept something
less than the mean return
in order to guarantee,
to get rid of the risk.
So in this case, even with
storage being somewhat costly,
when they're risk
averse, then we
could make them even
more risk averse.
They're going to be
more inclined to give up
some of the
consumption today, even
though it's going to not
survive the rats into tomorrow.
Because when they have
it, the consumption today
and consumption tomorrow are
more likely to be the same.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Beta matters.
If beta goes to zero, you
don't care about the future.
So obviously, these guys
would be very myopic.
And they would be behaving
very differently, and so on.
So all these parameters matter.
I guess I got lucky.
I mean, some of these
parameters were picked.
And I was complaining they
seem a little bit off,
like beta and risk aversion.
But that, along with
the depreciation rate
and the very carefully
calibrated technology,
did succeed in
producing the data.
So I want to come back to this.
We cheated a bit.
Because we had a
finite horizon and then
I kind of told you to ignore it.
That diagram was produced as
if the horizon was infinite.
And how would I know that?
Because if the horizon
is finite, then
unlike those figures,
the amount stored
is going to depend on
how many years are left.
Intuitively, if you're
at the terminal date--
it sounds kind of
foreboding, no?
The terminal date?
Well, you've got
one more year to go.
That's it.
Eat now.
You're not going to
be around tomorrow.
So there's not any
savings in seed.
There's not any storage.
Now you could move back
from there to the next
to the last date,
knowing that you're not
going to save tomorrow.
You're still facing a choice
between today and tomorrow,
or this year versus next year.
So you could solve that
two period problem.
We call this working
back from the end, right?
We start at the last date.
We move to the next
to the last date
and solve the
maximization problem.
Substitute in the
values, and then we
have the maximized utility
at the next to last date
because we've already
solved that problem.
And then you move to
the third to last date.
But it's still going to look
like a two period problem
because we've collapsed
the last date and the next
to the last date into one
because we already solved
that last two period problem.
I'm going to show
you some notation.
I'm not sure you could
possibly be following me.
But I'll say it
in English first.
And then we'll do
it in the notation.
Anyway, there's a sequence
of two period problems.
As you let the horizon
t get larger and larger,
you're kind of farther and
farther away as you go back
toward t equal 1.
So the larger is that
distance between t
equal 1 and cap T. Especially
when beta is close to zero,
it's as if you're solving
an infinite horizon problem.
And that is the way numerically
to solve it, literally.
Start with the last day.
Do the two period optimization.
So the next to the last to the
last, plug in the solution,
move to the third
to last, and so on.
And then keep iterating forever.
Well, keep iterating
until the solution isn't
changing anymore.
And then, amazingly,
you will be guaranteed
to have solved the
infinite horizon problem.
So let me show you
the math of that.
And I apologize the
notation changes a bit.
This is from engineering
or economics.
It's called a control
problem, the Bellman problem.
So x is the current state,
which in our application
was the current harvest
plus the storage.
And y are the control
variables, namely,
how much you can store
and save for tomorrow.
That you get to choose.
Also, you choose consumption.
You can choose two out of three,
that determines the third.
And then you'll get
beta times the utility
for next year, which in this
control problem language
is this so-called value
function which has in it
why the endogenous
variable chosen today
becomes the state of the
world for next period.
So this is the two
period problem.
Utility contemporary,
utility today, and utility
next period, it's really already
maximized utility from tomorrow
on.
But think of it as a
two period problem.
That's the way I was
describing [INAUDIBLE]..
And what is the
overall solution?
It has to do with J, the guess
about the next to last date,
and so on.
But T now, here's my apology.
T is not time.
T is the mapping in this
language of Bellman.
And I realized only
this morning that it
might have been better to change
the notation to be consistent.
But T does not refer
to the time horizon.
T refers to the mapping from
the utility from next period
on to the utility today.
This is the maximized
utility, where J is a given.
You're surely going to have
questions about this, so
interrupt me.
Now there's something called
a contraction mapping.
And don't worry about
the details here.
But it turns out we have
this mapping T here,
and we have the underlying
space being a metric m
and we have some
distance metric,
some way to measure distance
in that metric space.
Then the difference between
two guesses about v times beta
is an upper bound for the
distance between the result.
So, again, here we should think
about v1 and v2 as guesses
for the right-hand side.
So this would be J1 and J2.
And then we apply T to it, and
this would be TJ instead of Tv.
So that's probably the
second thing to correct,
is to change the v's to Js.
Anyway, the point is
the distance over here
on the left-hand side is
not greater, typically less
than the distance on
the right-hand side.
And so intuitively what
that means is things
are going to contract.
Hence this is called
a contraction mapping.
Or to put it more formally,
if you start with an arbitrary
J or an arbitrary v, and
keep iterating, start here,
get this, put it in.
Do it again.
Get this.
As N gets large, and we keep
successively applying that
mapping to an initial
guess value of v,
we're going to converge
to something called v*.
And when T of v* is
equal to v*, we are done.
That's the infinite
horizon solution.
That's like saying the J up
here and the TJ is also J.
So the time horizon
has disappeared.
So this is kind of tough stuff.
I thought it would be
better to show you the math
rather than be
mysterious about it.
But let me pause for questions.
All right.
We have everything we
needed in that application
to apply the
contraction mapping.
Our guess for v0 is
just the solution
to the last period problem.
We get the optimized value, as
if you were at the last date.
Substitute in the
maximized utility number.
And then go to the
next to the last period
and iterate again with that
new guess for the second period
utility.
And just keep
iterating, and we'll
get to the infinite
horizon solution.
So we can think about applying
this technique more generally.
So this is a related, but
somewhat distinct problem.
It's in a contemporary
setting, a household
trying to maximize the
utility of consumption,
but facing stochastic earnings,
say, from year to year.
And they're limited in the
way that they can save.
But there is a savings account
in the bank at some interest
rate, or even a riskless
bond, like treasuries.
So it's like putting
stuff in the ground
today and getting
stuff out tomorrow.
That's like storage.
In fact, in the first
lecture, I said something
about these agrarian metaphors.
And we just jump like that.
We went from grain in the bin
as kind of a storage technology
to riskless bonds as another
way to store money over time,
hopefully with a positive yield.
Actually, the real rates
are negative right now.
So anyway, that's
a bit of a problem.
So we maximized utility.
And now I have the courage
to put infinite horizon here.
So we're going to maximize
discounted expected utility
over the infinite horizon.
Beta is still less than one.
This thing would converge.
So this term is finite.
And the choice will be
over how much to eat
and how much to save.
So the way to
think about this is
you're coming in
with a realization
of your stochastic income.
You're having the
amount of the bond
that you bought last period.
You get that back plus
the interest rate.
That's the resources
available today at T.
And you can either eat
that, or buy a bond
and carry it over
to the next period.
So this looks really similar to
the medieval storage problem.
A couple of comments about
it, as I tried to alert you.
The timing here is the date.
The dating is different.
So now, at t, this is no
longer a state variable.
This is a decision
variable, bonds
to becoming due next period.
Likewise, on the right-hand
side, this doesn't have a t.
It had a t minus 1.
Because the savings decisions
are dated at the time t
that you make the decision,
rather than the time
t where the yield comes in.
And this is also standard.
You just have to keep an
eye out in terms of what
the authors have in mind.
And this starts at date zero.
So you need some
initial conditions,
which should have been k at
t equals 0 minus 1 or k1.
This is also a typo.
This should have been
k minus 1, not k0.
And the y0 is fine.
That's the contemporary yield.
So I apologize
about these typos.
Although it is kind of
an interesting story.
They're not mine.
I took this slide
from somebody else,
and they had actually
made the mistake,
and it wasn't corrected
in the publication.
But we'll fix it.
The other thing
about the typos--
I know you hate them,
I do, too-- when
we did that input-output
matrix for Leontief last,
when we did the
last part of lecture
before the first part of
last lecture, the beginning
of Lecture 5, we went
back over Lecture 4,
and I was saying how much
of the service sector
you need as an input.
Produce one unit of
output of services.
How much do you need
from manufacturing
and raw materials?
It was right in the slide.
The typo had been corrected.
But that typo
exists in Wikipedia.
And it's still wrong there.
So what I'm saying
is, I work very
hard to eliminate the typos.
But sometimes,
they still persist.
If you're reading carefully,
though, you can spot them.
And please don't hesitate,
if you find other things
that you find questionable.
That's the bad part.
Then it becomes confusing about
whether there's a typo or not.
So if in doubt, ask us.
And we'll try to
answer questions.
AUDIENCE: Here, the kt
could be [INAUDIBLE],, right?
in the latter constraint,
and say that a kt just
are larger than minus k?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Oh, good question.
So borrowing is allowed.
So I referred to this
as a riskless bond,
as if you could save.
But in fact, if savings is
negative, you're borrowing.
So if you multiplied through
by the negative sign,
you'd have a minus kt less
than or equal to k bar.
So kt positive for
savings minus kt
would be now denoting borrowing.
And borrowing has an
upper bound, a lower bar.
So this formulation of the
problem allows borrowing,
but it's limited.
So that's a great question.
Thank you for asking.
Is it clear?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Another question is,
what is the difference
between the self-insurance
and full insurance?
Is the self-insurance--
that means we cannot borrow,
or we can borrow, but there
were some constraints like this.
We can borrow at a
certain range, or--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
so I actually took out
slides that I used to have.
Self-insurance is
what we've been
studying the whole lecture.
Because it's, like, one
village, or one person.
And they're pretty
much in isolation.
Here, it's still
self-insurance, although there
is this bond, or this borrowing
possibility at a fixed interest
rate, which I didn't tell
you where that came from.
But this is, like, partial
equilibrium problem
in which the agent
can borrow or lend
with the rest of the economy.
And that's still referred to as
self-insurance, although it's
a bit misleading.
Because one person's saving
is another person's borrowing.
But anyway, we're not doing
the general equilibrium here.
We're taking-- the
interest rate is given.
But the other thing
would be, what
if there were multiple
people like this,
and some people had high
income at a given date,
and other people had low
income at a given date?
Then we're back
to thinking about
whether they could make
deals with each other.
So we'll get there
actually next time.
But the risk-sharing
problem would be--
an extreme version
of that is get rid
of the storage
altogether and the seed.
Get rid of them.
Not the seed, get
rid of the storage.
Get rid of the bond.
But imagine these guys can
contract with each other,
write financial contracts,
or informal risk-sharing
arrangements with
each other so as
to pool the risk
that they're facing.
Like in the village, they
had scattered those strips.
So they're trying to stabilize
their starting point.
But on top of it, they could
be borrowing and lending.
They could be making a deal.
If I'm high and you're low, I'll
give you money, and likewise,
vice versa.
And that's not self-insurance.
That's kind of dynamics
of explicit risk-sharing
insurance.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
No, it's a great question.
As I said, I used to have
more slides here about that.
And I thought it was a little
too early in the class.
But there are clearly
trade offs about--
how can I put this--
whether or not
want to do self-insurance
as in a dynamic problem
versus whether or not
want to do risk sharing,
but do it repeatedly
over many dates.
In fact, the very first lecture,
after we did economic science,
we went through some
example economies.
And I gave you five of them.
And the very first two
were one, medieval villages
with these scattered
strips that we've
been studying now, last time and
today, implicitly, or the Thai
temple scheme.
You remember the
Thai temple scheme?
They had low land and high land.
If the monsoon rains
were really abundant,
the low land flooded
too much, and they only
got crops off the high land.
And when the monsoon rains
were adequate or low,
then the highlands failed.
And what they did was contribute
their crops to the monks.
Not for eating, that
really threw me.
Because I know monks don't--
I mean, you can feed the monks,
but the monks don't feed you.
But nevertheless, they
were putting their crops
under the auspices of
the temple with the monks
and then handing it
out to people that
had either drought or flood.
So that's an active
risk-sharing scheme.
And your question
comes back to that,
which is comparing and
contrasting these two
different ways to handle risk.
OK, so this is Lecture 6.
There aren't quite
as many slides here.
But you can see there are
some very important concepts.
And we've now succeeded
in having both time
and uncertainty and dynamic
programming techniques
for solving that.
So we'll come back and
use those techniques
in subsequent lectures.
Next Tuesday is a lecture
on Pareto optimality, which
is finally the full blown
general equilibrium,
although we've kind of
been going back and forth
and getting very close to that
in the last couple of lectures.
But in the lecture
on Tuesday, we
will fully embrace it and
talk about efficiency.
OK, that's all for today.